STAFF
BOZAK, AS THE BLUES COMPLETE A
LINE CHANGE.
NOWLEURY
MAKES THAT SAVE AND DARREN THAT
WAS PROBABLY MORE OF A PASS NHL
GAME WEARING NUMBERT OFF.
>> Darren: THAT'S A DANGEROUS
SITUATION, HE HAD THEAHEAD,
GAUDETTE TIPS IT.
AND THE BLUT BUT
YELLED AT HIM JUST BEFORE THE
BLACK HAWK PLAYER GOT TOWARDS
HIM.
>> John: AND
WAS TIPPEDSLOT.
>> John: NOW GLOVED DOWN BY
WALMAN.
LOOSE IT BACK FROM
KYROU.M
FLEURY.
>> Darren: ALWAYS A GOOD BATTLE
BETWEEN TWO BUDDIES, D
WAS RIGHT.
HOW'S THAT?
>> Darre NET, WHAT A SAVE SCAND
THAT SAVE BY FLEURY, THAT ON AM.
AND THE HAWKS IN FRONT TO TOEWS
AND TIPPED JUST THROUGH THE AND
HARDMAN AS HE HAD CHICAGO
FIVE GAMES IN A  NO
ICING.
NOW I THINK I'VE SEEN
WITH 5:15 TO GO FIRST
CHICAGO STADIUM, ANDUP.
AND NOW IT'S TOEWS.
HE'LL GUIDE ITISTENED AND YOUR
KIND OF TRA OVER TOWARDS MY
RIGHT RIGHT NOW, THIS IS NOT A
VERY HAPPY
THOMAS, HERE'S
GET BINNINGTON LEANING TOWARDS
HIS LEFT AND F
THROUGH.
>> Darren: I AGREE WITH YOU.
ANDHE PASS BY
KRUG.
AND NOW KRUG GET GET IN THERE O
VISION THERE OF ROBERT THOMAS.
>> John: T BLUES DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB HERE OF PRESSURIN
BINNINGTON GOT A P P BIT, NOW T